Is anyone else deep into Nail TikTok at the moment?
Specifically gel x Nail TikTok?
Because I am and I'm also extremely fucking delusional.
So I don't need encouragement
to try and learn something that I'm not remotely qualified to do
after watching hours and hours of these girly pops
doing the most gorgeous nails from the comfort of their own home.
And can I just say
they sold me at the fact that they don't have to leave the house
because one thing about me is I genuinely don't like doing that.
That's why you don't get fun Errands day vlogs from me because errands,
I think that they're a chore and I don't really like that.
One night
I went on to Amazon and I bought everything that I needed to do
to do my own gel X at home.
The first set that I did was just a plain one colour.
I just wanted to take it easy and learn the process and they were okay.
I definitely had some areas that I could improve it. Anyway,
I fell in love with mermaid nails.
I don't know if you've seen those,
but they're just ethereal.
My inner child screams with delight every time I see them and I'm like,
I want those on my hands.
And so the other night I decided to give them a go.
And this is your sign if you're thinking about doing your own gel X,
doing them at home because this
Is my first attempt at nail art
and I feel like it's only gonna get better from here
and I lowkey aye like these nails make me so fucking happy
and I think that that is the point right
they might not be your cup of tea
they might not even be my cup of tea in two weeks
I'm gonna wanna change them because that's what I do with nails
I get sick of them but for today I'm so happy okay
I will show you what I did
because I'm proud of myself for trying these things
I did an aura now with chrome
and then we've got the water droplets with the nail glue
then this one is blooming gel
I've done a little swirl moment with a few different colours
and we've also got the water droplets
this one is a blooming gel with a chrome moment and there is um
sorry for pulling the fingers
there's a pearl at the bottom
this one's just like a plain pink with a couple of pearls
couple of water droplets and a starfish stop
and then I'm quite happy with this one
it's mainly chrome but then I did some blooming gel down the bottom
and we've got water droplets and we got starfish
and honestly these just make me feel like a magical sea creature
and why wouldn't you wanna feel like that?
I've linked everything that I used in my Amazon storefront
but honestly
if you Have been thinking about trying your own gel X at home.
I think you should. I think you should fucking go for it
because the amount of compliments I've had on my nails as well,
I'm like, really?
Thank you. I did them myself.